I can only imagine oh I said I was vets
I can only imagine the gym is [ __ ]
but no I'm chatting with our guests Oh a
couple of celebrities just chatting I
see Tom Green yeah welcome man how are
you it's good to see you
couple of celebrities just chatting yeah
yeah you already said that so I don't
know why you just wanted to say I can't
stop as a celebrity again
no no Tom's a celebrity but you just
said a couple of some what's happening I
see I have no left hungry I see why I
love it I heard you were at my show in
Montreal yeah right yeah I didn't see it
there but I heard you were there and
that we were tweeting after that's right
yeah that like Montreal I saw you
country all yeah we did radio but
separate times right and like like in
the same station I imagine you draw a
lot better than I do i do okay up there
but not that's weird because you guys
are just a couple of celebrities we are
but we different celebrities from
different countries all right
what oh I'm almost from Montreal I'm
from Ottawa which is an hour and a half
drive down the road I've been there once
it's a nice place yeah it's the capital
it's a nice conservative City you know
we've got the Parliament Buildings yeah
it's very popular in Ottawa you must be
yeah yeah I mean you know I depending on
who you ask I guess yeah yeah how did
the tour up in Canada quite a bit so how
did the out of the conservative town
take to you when you started becoming
very famous for doing very things that
were not conservative I'd say you know
it was I think I I sometimes think that
the show would never have really
happened if I wasn't from Ottawa because
it's very non intimidating the city like
you can go on the street and barge up to
people with a camera right and you don't
feel like they're gonna kill you
right you just feel they're gonna get
confused and kind of wander away and
that was always fun to watch the
confusion on these sort of uptight
conservative nature of the of the city
and the politics and there's everyone
walking to their government jobs and so
but yeah it was it was it was it was
pretty good it's pretty good place to
start out a gorilla man on the surgery
TV show you're saying you get to America
and like you realize people will kill
you but you've already started this
thing so someone just asked me about
this in the hallway this video I did the
very--it was a very first video I shot
when we went to end
TV it's called under cutters pizza can I
tell you something over too long yeah
Travis and myself Travis Travis is our
Phil he's in the booth right there yeah
no next to you yeah what's up um
Travis and I probably amongst ourselves
bring up under cutters hundred uh
probably at least once every two weeks
like you like your cutters he's a
delivery guy and I have a plain cheese
pizza and a fishing tackle box full of
pizza toppings and I follow the real
pizza guy to his delivery in Long Island
and then when I walk up to the house
with the pizza guy wondering why I'm
following him the guy comes out to buy
his pizza I quickly make the same pizza
and offer to sell it to him for cheaper
finder cutters but then the guy who is
there working on his car from Long
Island then attacks me with a hammer
basically so that first I was just mad
that I was on his property and Tom
explains to him I'm just trying to offer
you a pizza for cheaper yeah mad that I
was pointing the camera at him and stuff
but it was like that was sort of like
why just welcome to New York you know
yeah he's like mother kind of Americans
are different than people from Ottawa
the tackle box for the topic yeah it is
so ballsy though you walk right next to
the pizza delivery guy that right there
was literally our first first shoot
because I did I did the chauffeur for
many years in Canada on public
television public access and then this
was the first one where we went shot
with the MTV crew and where we went back
to the back to the office in Times
Square at Viacom and all the producers
were all kind of freaked out okay
there's the guy with the hammer yeah he
kicked your tackle box ow that was real
- yeah but he was such a character he
would fight to get the you know this guy
was such a character it was just sort of
made the whole bit yeah I mean that
that's obviously a better reaction yeah
do you do you kind of refocus after that
and go like okay we should do things
that might not result in me getting
threatened with a hammer or do you go
we're in now we got MTV this is what we
got to be doing it was always kind of
like if you could get to somewhere
around that line where you the hammer
comes out but you don't get hit by the
hammer thank you actually see you hear
me saying in the video
when I'm saying to talk about the camera
guy said this is the line Matt this is
the line Matt you know because the
camera guy didn't really quite know the
drill yet right he didn't know when it
was time to really go yeah he was sort
of like trying to walk up to the guy and
get a shot no no this is where we run
this is where we run we did have to get
clearance for him that was a whole
interesting thing hi did you need to pay
my yes right yeah I think they did pay
him a few bucks yeah we were already
offering him a pizza for cheaper you
think that money wouldn't be such an
issue hundred countries you know so
what'd he do just like did the producers
go look look we're doing a TV shows for
MTV we'll give you 100 bucks like we
just sign off so he sent some production
assistants back over to his house and
and you know talked him into it and was
he better natured about it when he
realized what it was yeah he ended up
doing an interview about the prank for
vh1 said that was one of the I know they
did a pranks funniest pranks show and he
did an interview for it and he was
pretty funny in that too he was you know
I think I think sometimes he was like my
parents I did a lot of pranks on them
they'd get angry in them in the midst of
that sure right then once they kind of
cool down they realize us kind of kind
of funny
sure people like to see themselves on TV
you know how long did it take it once
your when your parents saw themselves on
TV freaking out because of the [ __ ]
mobile yeah because you know what you
did was overnight you you painted their
car with a pornographic image on the and
you wrote [ __ ] mobile on it yeah and
then when it was time for them to go to
work in the car filming him I was
basically a bin that we kept the garbage
in that was right beside the car and I
got in that at about 6:00 in the morning
I filmed it my us filming this myself
yeah and so your dad's now walking to
work he's working at the bus stop or
wherever and he's furious because he
can't drive his car to work because
there's pornography I see him sort of
start to crack a smile right about here
because he kind of realizes that [ __ ]
mobile is funny kind of very okay that's
it
because he realized it was funny yeah I
think you kind of realized what good
work and so after that was he okay with
it
yeah you know see my dad's a bit of a
ham to say that he's a funny guy so he
kind of like would get we had to do a
lot of the pranks like in the middle of
the night just to kind of get him kind
of off guard because otherwise he's
playing for cameras or do extreme things
that there was no way they'd be happy
about like the first big one was when I
painted the whole house multiple colors
plaid we fell it really this crosshatch
you know crap right because they own the
house yeah I mean that's they've
invested a lot of money so the white
part of the house we painted that I
think I painted that once you know plan
yeah and you know my parents you know
work were you know hard hard work and
you know middle-class you know they
didn't you know you know they didn't
just like this job
well they blurred out the pornographic
image because it was on television oh
and and what Tom did to the hood of his
parents car yeah it was so inappropriate
that you couldn't show it I with it well
it's just kind of some pornography what
actions was it to ladies join each
other's time together you know with a
with a and use it alongside your dad
right yeah then I do drive it to the bus
stop which was actually that's always a
fun part about making those videos was
that wasn't really something that I'd
sort of first saw when we always thought
of the bit it's actually it's a woman
going down on another where we go
there's the amateur that's what it is
the funniest part of the video is
actually when I Drive into the bus stop
at the end because there's all the
neighbors are sitting there looking at
this and it was not it was not a it was
only saying well I was just just them
looking at the pic at the image you know
was was did they know it was he's
filming it
I'm filming at all huh yeah I filmed it
all any normally I didn't normally film
everything but in this bit I did because
I had to hide in that box because they
could see out into the front I wanted to
get the shot of him looking at the for
the very first time and then I want yeah
exactly and I want to be right there so
we didn't normally do hidden camera that
we never hid the camera so right right
but in this case it was necessary did
did neighbors know it was his car when
you drove up to the bus stop yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know he's very funny to
his he took all the furniture out and
farm animals in the house yeah boy
tonight yeah yeah it's you know I it's
great kid in New York man because like
that was sort of like the thing about
about you know for me was like that was
the moment that I kind of realized oh
look like I actually got a job in
television MTV's picked us up and we
moved me down here to New York City and
you know I you know I'm I'm you know I'm
at Caroline's all weekend I come here
maybe you know I'm not in New York as
much as I'd like to be in New York but
every year our seat on the road a lot on
the road traveling to her in full time
you know like life on the road I do like
it yeah I do like it I mean I get it
gets a little tiring sometimes
constantly traveling but I do I do love
it and I started doing stand-up when I
was a teenager and you know when I was
16 and I did it till I was about 20 and
you know I quit I quit when I went back
to school and did broadcasting school
and I kind of regretted that for a long
time I want to quit for about about 15
years oh but you kind of branched out
into another finger so I basically
started doing the show I kind of felt
like doing the show was kind of like
doing stand-up I mean I'd I'd write
jokes and we'd do the thing from the
audience and everything but I wasn't
touring you know I wasn't doing I didn't
so then maybe ten years ago I just
started doing and stand up again and
really started doing it really for the
first time you know in some ways you
know I never was on the road you know
liver young yeah but when I was a
teenager you know I was at Yuk Yuk's in
Ottawa and I would go down there every
week you know couple times a week and
just be at the club and you know I was a
huge fan of Harland Williams term and
Norm Macdonald and Jeremy hots where the
were the guys that were you know kind of
the Canadian headliners at the time had
not made it in the US yet and you know
Heartland was like 24 or something like
now he's one basically one of my best
friends Harlan and I we just did do
shows together and stuff and do you do
full weekend somewhere do you go do one
night and leave
I do full weekends yeah like I'm at
Caroline's front on Saturday but yeah
I'm doing laughs Boston
is coming up I'm doing that Club I'm
gonna be a governor's I think I'm doing
a one-nighter at governor's and then I'm
doing stress factory I'm doing a weekend
there in a few weeks so yeah I will
though I go all over the country well
and yeah I like doing the weekends I do
one-nighters too but I like doing the
weekends I like to settle in and you
know snow and spent some time the city
not have to move very much not have to
travel as much but you know I and yeah
that's cool
I just just did Israel just as shown
Israel for the first time to do we're in
Israel Tel Aviv and just did what I did
a one show there and all over you know
England and I mean it's pretty MTV
blasted the show around the world kind
of amazing kind of you know lucky break
so we did that you know because I can go
play Australia now and think you know
sometimes people are coming out to the
show certainly when I started doing tour
and again they were coming up to you
they didn't even know what the show was
gonna be and right right you can be
standing up for something weird yeah
yeah the first the first few years of
touring you know it was a lot of people
yelling out lines from Freddy got
fingered and stuff like that but now now
that's what I like playing comedy clubs
and you know people people know how to
how to behave yeah comedy show sometimes
yeah sometimes they do some you find
that they don't sometimes as well you're
always I'm sure you're ready to go
Friday they get a little too drunk can
be a little much you get that
bachelorette party that's yelling out
the bump um song or something like that
you're like I don't want to yeah it can
happen I just want to do my jokes right
yeah it can happen yeah yeah yeah create
a funny I though like Tom's talk show
you have all these things you do you're
very innovative yeah I just you know and
when people don't give you a job right
in broadcasting I've just sort of and
then sort of consistently been the case
with me I have to go make my own we went
to broadcasting school I'm late I made
the show because nobody would ever give
me a show right and then and then you
know few years later you know after MTV
you know I wanted to do a show nobody
was giving me a show so I made a built a
web studio in my living room you know
right few years after that I'm like
maybe I'll go to stand up you know it's
it's I'm not sort of you know
consistently sort of getting work
hand it to me so I have to create my own
so yeah weird opportunities sometimes
who is more as we all do who's more
upset with you your parents after the
[ __ ] mobile or Glenn hump lick after you
put his cell phone number out into the
middle of Times Square for everybody to
see you guys you know like a lot of the
details I do you know a lot of it I do I
was as a big as a big fan so that was a
I mean it's a funny thing did that was a
mistake actually an actual mistake so
like you didn't mean to actually give
out the number yeah we were doing a
contest where we were gonna give out one
number from Glenn's phone number every
week okay and Glenn didn't know and
there was a there was a Wheel of Fortune
type thing where you're the numbers turn
around and his phone number was on the
back and if it turned each number around
he would see one number it was in The
Times Square studio right at MTV and we
kind of miscalculated and didn't realize
that the back was pointing at the window
and there's always like 100 kids
standing on a street so they got the
number the kids on this behind the sign
which is in front of a window we can't
clearly so they got the number then they
put it on the internet and then his
number was ruined he man it was very mad
at me yeah yeah but you made it into a
thing for the show you were like look I
mean we did this by mistake but it's
it's kind of funny that it happens so
Glenn and I don't talk anymore actually
how come uh yeah I think he's mad at me
for what I don't know I'm not sure I'll
would next time I talk to him it's been
about 15 years since I've talked to
Glenn why I mean there must've been
something that he got mad at though
might have been a all of the things
added up together everything he just
decided no more yeah the last time you
talked to him when it was like 15 no but
I mean it was an argument er yeah we had
a little falling-out I don't get into
the details of it but it was kind of
like you know like things got a little
weird there for a minute in in my life
you know I mean I'm we moved down here
we all came down to LA together my
friends and I who were kind of helping
on the show and you know everybody
everything just life got weird and then
they kind of some of them moved back and
maybe we're kind of you know it's weird
when the show gets huge and you become a
giant celebrity right it you know there
was just some
you know some issues that arose I don't
like to talk about possibly jealousy to
a 1-point I don't think I was so much
that no I just I don't know I don't know
III are you man and him as he mad at you
that's a good question I'm not I'm not
mad at him no okay I'm not mad at him I
think I was mad at him for a minute you
are and he was also mad at me and then
he was mad that I was mad at him and now
he might think that I'm mad at him I
don't know but I'm not mad at him any do
you want to reach out yeah I have
reached out I have reached out I to be
honest with you I think there is sort of
a slight and this by the way you know
probably I don't know maybe cuz you know
the show well only interesting to you
and a select amount of people that
really know that are into the weeds of
the politics right of my old show we're
talking about my co-host on the on the
show yeah but but you know I have a lot
of love for Glenn hump look you know I
do and and we had a lot of we started
the show to use in the early years of
doing the show I met him when I was
doing college radio at Ottawa University
and I would go in at midnight till 2:00
a.m. every Friday night and do this
phone and talk show and he was on from
2:00 a.m. till 6 a.m.
playing industrial music and and we
would meet as we passed it at 2:00 at
2:00 in the morning in the studio and
that's how we became friends so but you
know I we have mutual friends I you know
Phil you are a guy that drinks the
coffee in the window on the on the show
and he's still friends with both of us
how did you reach out in what I just
drew Phil Phil is how long ago you know
basically you know somewhat
semi-regularly we talk about this
because Phil Phil is you know one of my
best friends if not my best friend I'm
sure he's my best friend because I've
known him since I was 14 years old and
you know we're you know it's funny how
you he's my best friend you know it's
like you know yeah that matter I've
other good friends too and no offense to
my other for sure but he's number one
yes yes no better than the other one I
would say so the best I'd say is the
best friend yeah yeah oldest friend so
you reached out recently yeah like well
cuz I go I go home to Ottawa a lot every
summer cuz my pair
so they're my brother's era and you know
I go home every you know when I was up
in Montreal after the after I saw you
Michelle my parents live in a lake so
it's like it's like you go home to see
your parents it's like vacation it's a
going on vacation up there Canada's
beautiful in the summer it's a winter
it's not so little rough a little rough
up there did you at any point fall into
like Hollywood world where we're because
you go from public access show in Canada
just like nobody's gonna give me a job
so I just make this thing up and me and
my buddies are doing this wacky show to
be caught like you know within a year or
two of being in the States you're one of
the most recognizable people anywhere
you know I mean you're completely
weirdest thing about MTV was it's
different than today right yeah MTV was
sorta like um sometimes say MTV is kind
of like took the place of what almost
like the entire Internet does now you
know if you if you cared about music if
you cared about you know pop culture you
go to MTV so all young people would go
watch MTV everybody would watch MTV now
people go to youtube they watch music
videos on YouTube everyone you know so
it was sort of a shell shock you know
like like you know I I was I was excited
when the show got picked up we don't
have didn't have MTV in Canada either
back then so I know what MTV was you
know but I didn't really grow up with it
I didn't grow up with it
so I didn't really understand how
pervasive it was in American society you
know when the show was on MTV like they
started running promos and the way it
worked back then on MTV like there's the
promo department was bigger than the
programming department is basically MTV
just ran promos all day yeah so before
the show was even on the air they were
running these promos all day of the show
which was Clips goofy Clips and um you
know it was like literally like a week
after I moved to New York it was sort of
we couldn't walk around in Times Square
outside without everybody knowing the
show so it was sort of surreal it was it
was it was definitely a bit of a culture
shock yeah you're already four how many
years are you on here I was only in New
York for a year actually then then I
moved out to Los Angeles with the show
and we did the show out there for
another season Hansen how many years on
MTV did it run be
ran it for about four years but I was
really on MTV only for about a year and
a half you had a lot of them was shot in
Canada yeah a lot most of it was shot in
Canada and then we were actually doing
the show on MTV for about a year and a
half and I quit the show when I got
cancer
people think the show got canceled the
show did not get canceled how did you
find out you had cancer he's sick I mean
you might have told this drives don't
write oh right my right testicle was
kind of swollen why is that I don't I
get to a little I don't know I'm not
trying to make you guys think about your
testicles yeah I was think about him
anyway it's weird yeah it's fine weird
talking but no I mean I talk about a lot
actually so testicles actually honestly
I just felt like after saying that and
then I paused yeah and then a the
uncomfortable pause I know you're not
uncomfortable you definitely don't seem
uncomfortable no it just seemed like an
interesting part I'm to pause just to
swim in that sort of like let's just I
just wanted to pause there I like that
yeah yeah no I'll tell you this like
young guys out there listening you can
get cancer in your testicles
they took my right testicle I still have
my left left testicle everything's fine
but you know if you ever feel like
anything's wrong go to the doctor right
away because you will die if you don't
go to the doctor are you caught it early
I caught it early and I fortunately was
paranoid enough to to go to the doctor
right away and we we filmed it all and
we made a show out of it and put it on
MTV how long after you found out did
they cut it out like almost immediately
yeah yeah they go and they don't they
don't they don't they don't hack through
your scrotum you know no they don't
how do they get it they don't go through
your scrotum my scrotum you think they
just don't believe ottoman act pop it up
in there right no they cut you up like
sort of in your abdomen you know it's
kind of like under your like sort of on
your pube pubic area like under like in
the taint area just like right up there
above yeah I see then they go in from
above and then they kind of like shucks
it out like an oyster why do they do
that it did you shuck it out like an
oyster yeah Wakeman I've heard you know
under general and but why do they do it
that way why do they shuck it out like
an oyster oh it's just it's I think it's
just easier a lot of veins and tubes and
whatnot is your way to go in through you
know you think if they just open the
bottom they just kind of feel bad and
then your scrotum is all stitched up you
know on your scrotum being stitched
Franken scrotum write that before how
long were you off the if you wanted they
can't see your shots anything a
relatively quick operation no they
didn't cancel my one end though I I quit
and regretted no no no I don't actually
went back a couple years later did
another show with them the talk show
right yeah you know I had like I I
basically did a bunch of movies and I
was I was look the real reason I stopped
those cuz like they did this thing
called a lymph node dissection which is
the real invasive surgery where they cut
they cut me up from here to here oh my
god and they take your intestines out of
your body and then they go back and they
cut your lymph nodes off the back of
your spine see and then they look at
them under a microscope to see if you've
got cancer and your lymph nodes that's
the only way to test where they have a
better take you know they have an MRI
which they did and the MRI said that
there was no cancer but there's like a
1% chance if the cancer was just fresh
there - it was too microscopic to see
there's a 1% chance that the cancers
there something you give is the thing
about cancer that's like interesting I
guess yeah and kind of a drag also is
it's all about these sort of choices you
have to make based on percentages based
on research that might not be completely
accurate
you know they've learned a lot more
about cancer even since I had it but
testicular cancer but so they say okay
with testicular cancer to give you a
little scientific sort of way it works
cuz you get testicular cancer you get
your your your balls swollen there's did
they do an ultrasound they can tell you
got cancer so then they know it spreads
from there to the lymph nodes from the
lymph nodes to the lungs from the lungs
to the brain Lance Armstrong had it all
the way up to his brain you know really
yeah I mean he's fine right it's highly
susceptible to chemotherapy if you get
the right
testicular cancer yeah as I forget which
one you know melanoma or serous I forget
what they're called I've actually forgot
what they call but so regardless they
because they know the direction it
spreads goes your lymph nodes first if
it's not in your lymph nodes you don't
have to have chemotherapy right if it's
in your lymph nodes you have to have
radiation chemotherapy so they did the
they did the MRI they said well you know
it's not in your lymph nodes but there's
a 1% chance it's in your lymph nodes so
here's your choice will cut your body
open like a like I will like a gut yeah
right and it's going to be the most
painful thing that you've ever been
through in your entire life and you're
gonna be like you know probably not able
to walk for a couple of months really
mouth yeah yeah you know you're wouldn't
be able to go bad for like six weeks Wow
then and then you're you mean the
hospital for like five weeks and it's
gonna really really suck but you'll know
that you don't have cancer anymore and
you won't have to have chemo but if if
we take your lymph nodes out and we look
at them and it is in there then you have
to have have the chemo right so couldn't
you have just gotten the chemo to be
preventative we could and that was
another choice yeah that's another
choice or we could just give you the
chemo but the choice was wait six months
and we'll see if it grows and if it
shows up and you get the chemo and so I
didn't you know my choice was well I
don't want to sway sit around for six
months not knowing if I got cancer and
then have to have chemo anyway so I'm
just gonna take him out and and I did
that and it was an unnecessary surgery
because I didn't have it so it's like
they were there unnecessary and [ __ ]
around so your lymph nodes so you're
okay yeah and they put everything Steve
a big scar on your chest yeah and now
you yeah sure it's pretty good
definitely pretty good that's not as bad
as I thought
so they went in there take everything
out and go all the way down to Richmond
effects you must be great though you
know it's uh it's uh yeah I you know in
the hospital yeah I hope it was probably
you know i i'd like you know tubes
coming out of me and said how painful
was it was it early I didn't so we were
filming
the show and the morning after the
surgery glenn public shows up and i was
like in sort of a fetal position
basically screaming in pain the FIR
whole first day after the surgery now
when low jump what [ __ ] i had morphine
epidural going into my spine and you
know but glenn walked in the room my
parents were sitting there like my mom
was probably crying I was probably
crying and it was really bad I don't
honestly was I think that changes you
though like when you realize like pain
can be that bad like it was sort of like
a burning like my whole spine felt like
it was burning you know and so I don't
really actually really feel pain anymore
because like your tolerance can went so
high yeah it's like the other stuff man
as they said yeah it was it was it was
worse than I could have ever imagined
I'm surprised even with an epidural and
of morphine yeah yeah it was sued for
about the first 24 hours it was just
like and then it sort of faded a bit so
did you think at one point this is never
going to leave I thought that yeah and
you know honestly it didn't really fully
I was not really fully pain-free for
probably about ten years actually ten
year uh yeah possibly
permanent I'm actually probably I still
have a little bit of pain from it but
you don't even notice it because it was
so bad so much less than it was Wow
right that's a really invasive operation
did that hurt so bad what do they do
that hurts so much I think it's just
nerve damage so they cut through all the
stuff and then your nerves get like you
know that it's just scrape and [ __ ] off
your spine I think if you think like
when you know you know you think you
know you cut someone over they just tie
it so it up and you heal and you're back
to normal but it's not really like that
right you're permanently why did he do
chemo well I didn't have to yes oh no no
I understand that but if now looking
back knowing what you know would he
would you've just gotten the
preventative chemo just know that what
what I would have what I could have done
is I could have no I wouldn't even had
to have done chemo I could have actually
just waited and I would gone into the
doctor every month or every two weeks or
something for six months and if it
hadn't appeared in six months then I
would have known it was not there so I
sort of think to myself sometimes but
you know but knew the choice was
you know then do you got spent six
months thinking oh my god do I have
cancer and my body you know right thank
you that early if they're checking for
it every two weeks then they catch it
you're brand new no problem I would
probably knowing now maybe don't know if
I would have waited six this is the
weird thing about these choices wait six
months yeah then it showed up then they
would have to do the surgery take it out
and give me chemo so I still would had
to have the surgery although a way if
they found it in two weeks you wouldn't
need the surgery anyway yeah oh okay
with chemo I probably would have done
the surgery just because you think it's
probably not gonna be that bad and we'll
be done yeah yeah but but now right now
and then you go man you know if I was
I'm not a gambler you know I always take
the most conservative yet approach to
everything you know the other thing is
is then you find out quicker that it's
in there so this was sort of like the
most aggressive approach to fighting the
cancer because yeah this is a weird
serious it is yeah
that's weird I wouldn't I wouldn't like
it's interesting though because I have
like like I I actually have kids that
come up to me kids like they're probably
in their 40s a lot of times my shows
like cuz they come up to at my stand-up
shows who like saw that saw that special
yeah you know when god you're sitting
there in recovery and and and getting
better and everything are you thinking
to yourself like first of all physically
I'm not doing the show right now but in
general I just don't wanna do the show
anymore
right so that's that's how we got into
this so I was in a lot of pain and I
didn't really want to go out in the
street and get chased by guys with
hammers right and I had you know I had
the opportunity to go to the movie road
trip and I yeah made the movie
Freddy got fingered called classic
Freddy got fingered I wrote and directed
so I was kind of like basically comes
wearing many hats yet for two years I
was basically like working on that right
and I I sort of like had you know the
ability to leave the show because of
being sick and go do that so I did that
but uh you know I it's you know I'm sure
I don't
I think if I had not gotten cancer I
would not have quit the show and that's
when Jackie ass came around
yeah how many years have to a year after
I think it's pretty much right after
yeah yeah right after and I kind of
stole a bunch of [ __ ]
in my opinion yeah I know all the guys
and you know I don't I don't I don't
know that it was like that so much I
don't know I mean they did do a lot of
the exact same things that I did okay
that's kind of what I meant by that in
more colloquial terms I'm not sure if
you I'm not sure how that went down I
mean I was surprised I got to admit I
was surprised when I you know sort of
woke up then you know six months later
and sort of hey here you know BAM just
painted his parents house you know
painted house I mean painted the house
they just put animals in the house you
know yeah yeah Knoxville's dressed up as
an old man crashing into stuff in an
electric wheelchair you know I'm les
right but what about went where the one
guy gets on crutches yeah and he puts a
cast on his leg keeps falling down in
the pharmacy so I was kind of bummed
about that at first and but then I kind
of like don't even know if they knew
like cuz like right they have like the
way it works at MTV is like there's tons
of writers and producers and they're
just like you know everything gets
written down on a piece of paper and
it's got to get approved by the network
right and then the network says could go
do this and then you're assigned
something that you're allowed to do so I
don't even really know if they knew I've
never actually asked them I don't even
know if they know like that they were
doing so they might just have like an
MTV list of here's the pranks we're
gonna do
MTV might have known this is where we
got them from but they just got this
little I'll tell you the weirdest part
about this whole subject is I get asked
about this every time I am on a radio
show which one you know - I'm doing
stand-up is everyday talked about this
every single day and I always feel bad
cuz I'm buddies with steve-o johnny
Knoxville I mean I love these guys and I
love jackass
once you just ask them if you have to
talk about it every day why don't you
just ask no no I don't really care it's
more like it's more like I feel weird
like I don't want to go around no I'm
not like hating on jackass
no but I mean just for that you don't
want to answer the next time you know
one of us hacky jocks asks you the same
jackass question you're not either I
know I didn't they say I'm just saying
like we're shock jocks
I'm just saying I don't want the guys
thinking that I'm going around you know
talking smack oh never cuz now III
thought jackass was completely first of
all your thing to talk about say about
jackasses it was there's probably a lot
of there's a lot more different about
that show than there was the same yeah
it's right I mean I love jackass to
skateboard culture and I didn't like you
give someone could he got hurt yeah
that's never been your cup of absolutely
you don't like that when you went on
into the talk show yeah after the Tom
Green show when it was the kind of you
know late-night talk-show thing for MTV
and the guy came in and destroyed your
desk and you got super [ __ ] pissed
about it yeah yeah with the dude who did
it
sorry I think it was like the lead
singer from like Jesse James Dupree from
jackal jackal jackal was the van yeah
jackal you're the chainsaw guitarist
yeah and he chainsawed your desk up Wow
yeah and you got super [ __ ] pissed
about it on the show yeah I did get
pissed about it did you in that moment
go like oh this is probably how all
those people that I was [ __ ] with
felt uh no no well what was going
through my mind in them this is
interesting let me do you want to get
into the weeds oh please yeah yeah let's
go deep you gotta there's I mean you can
find the cliffs everywhere Tom Green
because its controversial
I love controversy I don't go for that
on this show I know I'll always we're
not pulling in my life this is
controversial because on the internet
this gets controversial oh this is good
because people have had a hard time sort
of understanding the dynamic of what was
going on in my mind when I got mad at a
guy for chainsawing my desk something
that I've done myself in the past I just
sawed my own desk right they they try to
call that the hypocrisy you try to call
it the hypocrisy right but what they
don't understand is that like to me like
my favorite thing in the world growing
up was when Letterman got mad at his
guests because the guests did something
that he wasn't supposed to do when
Crispin Glover tried to kick Letterman
and then he got kicked off the show this
was you know when Harvey Pekar came on
the show and was a jerk to Dave or when
you know all the stuff that happened
yeah and then and then and then
Letterman would get mad and you knew he
was actually mad that was the best TV
sure best TV and
you know when you do a talk show nobody
really ever does anything that they're
not supposed to do right so you never
really are actually mad so in this
situation he came out here's we asked
him to come out and play he's not inside
your house that floor
no no that's the this was in Burbank in
a beautiful downtown Burbank in and we
built the studio and that was the the
new Tom green show it was called we were
doing the show five nights a week live
our daily day and date the way the
late-night the way the night shows day
yeah yeah so he was not supposed to saw
the desk now there's a there's a
subtlety to the the reason why I got mad
though so we we we tried to basically
recreate sort of the the feeling of
Johnny Carson's original New York set
yeah so that desk is actually if you go
online and look at pictures of Johnny
Carson's early black-and-white New York
set that desk is very similar to the
exact way that did he cut it have for
just right I just did that but but we
had that desk built you know like
Johnny's dad sure because it cost a lot
of money you know it's like Hollywood
set design company you know says okay
well that's gonna be and I was producing
the show and MTV didn't really want to
spend like 10 grand to make a desk when
we could have gotten got one at IKEA
right more people going crazy the
audience when he did it though yeah
everyone was having fun yeah whoo but
then I was like mad cuz I just got a
huge argument with my this was like the
first week of the show I just fought to
like build this desk with and you know
you know I mean they throw money around
at MTV like ten grands not that much to
them but you know they you fight for it
yeah and then I knew um our beautiful
Johnny Carson homage desk you know is
now ruined and what are we gonna do and
tomorrow night it's gonna have this crap
right now gyah mad at him right there so
right there I'm Masoud he says yeah I'm
doing well I told him are you gonna pay
for this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
he told me to do it that's Bert to brow
our producer who who actually started
the Jerry Springer Show which
interestingly enough this is starting to
look a little bit yeah but so I'm asking
him now whether or not he knew that that
he was gonna do that and hearing no your
thought is like I'm really pissed right
now
yeah so what's good TV is I'm gonna go
with this feeling
so there's actually kind of like I
actually was like yeah exactly
look I'm gonna actually like really run
with the fact that I'm angry and let
everyone know that I'm angry and not
pretend that I'm not angry and right and
let that honesty come out and you know I
because I I remember like when I was a
in high school you know I had this VHS
tape of this one time Harvey Pekar was
on another testicular cancer survivor
well he is no longer alive but he's not
didn't die from the candy that a movie
about him a few years ago American
Splendor a comic book artist right she
would go on Letterman his New York guy
and he was completely you know you know
sort of would always get in arguments
with Dave and everyone didn't like him
though he did I remember you started
getting aggressive with Dave and I think
Dave banned him from the show at one
point and you know I remember one point
you know Letterman got mad at I was just
like you know oh yeah yeah okay Harvey
thanks for coming on the show with your
little he had this cart comic book with
your little rainy day fund for boys and
girls weekend weekly reader pamphlet
here earlier and I remember you had this
like rainy day fund for boys and girls
weekly reader pamphlet yeah and I just
played that over and over and again
because I just saw that like that just
sort of the carnage of that moment and
so you know then in in this moment I'm
actually holding him CD at one point I'm
gonna yeah thanks for bringing in your
little rainy day for fun for boys and
girls CD here so part of you is thrilled
if you get to be the angry guy on the
show even though you're legitimately
anger cause normally angry in the
I'm making other people angry right so
wait did you ever resolve it with this
guy not really and and and is but you
know I've tried to resolve it because
like you know whenever I've talked about
it you know on occasion over the years I
always let him know right now I'll let
him know if he's listening Jesse James
Dupree no hard feelings I was actually
super happy that this happened you know
right but angry angry happy that I'm
happy that you were sorry that I was
angry how long was your show on this
show was on for not you know we did 60
episodes did you cancel the you quit
this one got canceled yeah this one got
canceled I'd never really kind of
understood why I mean I guess it was
doing well but very expensive
yeah I do desk every day I think what it
was was MTV is very they really like to
control everything that goes on the air
yes and I think it was just stressful
for them because you know every night
you know they couldn't control every
word you know I would talk for an hour
so so it was happening too fast for them
to be able to micromanage the show so I
think it was just driving him nuts it
also strikes me and I don't know cuz
I've never worked at MTV but it might be
a little bit difficult to mature at MTV
because they're constantly going after
young young young so you you're like
I've kind of outgrown the old show I
want to grow up into something that not
that this is like you know for 50 year
olds but this is a little bit more adult
yeah you know then the old weird lots of
great guests and I remember we'd like
you know tons a great guest with Marilyn
Manson Linkin Park all sorts of like
really cool people on you know I
honestly think they should have kept it
on obviously but but I think that's what
it was I think it was just difficult for
them to deal with what happened last
night on the show right on there dude
was this the dream is this why you went
to broadcast school so you could do a
talk show I think it was the dream but
now I don't think I want to do that you
know really because I just the nightly
talk show right so you keep the - by the
way I do still have the desk we rebuilt
the desk and I have the desk and it's in
my garage but the next day on the show I
mean the next day on the show was like
that for about a week and then and then
went on the weekend we had it recovered
and then
and yeah we had we had to have the desk
like that for I think was a few days it
was like that yeah did you get pissed
every time you saw it yeah probably yeah
still angry about just looking at it
yeah